hey it's brian happy new year brian
you're joining at 11
50 p.m my time i know for most of the
chat is in 2021
but uh i guess another question how many
people are in
central time zone so in the time zone
that's about to celebrate
the new year i was going to play nave
nave said
nate said he would accept the stafford
gambit
nave convinced me to give a game um just
with the opening choice we're gonna do
casual
four plus two because random time
control i'll be black
okay here we go
let's go
stafford gambit time
so this is a second staffer gambit of
the stream the first one
went really well
oh nave is just evan backwards
made some epiphany there
okay d3 amazingly enough hikaru
played the same move a few months ago
against a total scrub or total um
not scrub just like newer player
and uh walked into this trap and he got
a worse position
um it was part of his like random gambit
speed run
yeah scrub was a mean word i was just
trying to to think of like a
a word for newer player
um sorry people i didn't mean to offend
anyone
yeah every grand master was once a scrub
or a noob
that's another potential like uh quote
to put on a mug
i'm gonna have to find the hikaro game
because hikaru won in like
weird fashion like he played some 984
move early
okay
i've had this position maybe close to a
dozen times
in the past
an idea is to play bishop g4
so six minutes until the new year
i don't know if this game is going to
make it i might not be playing a game of
chess
or i might be i don't know
it'd be cool to start a game in 2020 and
then finish the game in 2021
[Music]
oh there's so much fun to be had there's
bishop c1 there's also bishop d2
i don't know what to do let's play
bishop c1
setting up queen d2 but also threatening
to take and fork
yeah i don't think people can hear like
on like my mic
i have a noise suppression filter but i
can hear like lots of
explosions in the distance i i don't
think it's gunshots hopefully not
pretty sure it's fireworks
or confetti cannons
but we'll have to save some confetti for
five minutes from now oh i could play a
blindfold game
and then when like when i put the
blindfold on i actually have the
blindfold
but then i won't know what time it is
but then i could i could say after the
game that i hadn't seen you guys in a
year
oh i could get my pawn cube let's get
the point here all the instructional
content
i recently reached 2 100 rapid rating
images
let's go because of you keep it up it's
loss
or it loss soon to be it win
appreciate that yeah very proud this is
gonna be close
oh okay here i can
oh i can play f4 this is funny
so i hit the the knight the knight's
pinned
if white takes i can safely take the
knight and the queen can't take back
because i'm
delivering check with the rook as well
and then i'll get my pawn cube let's go
yeah it's very important let's double
check
okay gonna go for the kill
oh can i checkmate with my pawn cube
oh it's so close
it's actually really close and i have to
walk my king in first
oh it's so so close
ah white's waiting no checkmate
let's go that was nice
good game dave always double check
ah i lost my pawn cube though my my pawn
cube had to
uncubify itself thank you coach
i reached 500 yellow in rapid and i hope
to progress to at least 800 in the 2021
as my new year goal
keep it up yeah keep it up don't stop
there
thank you californian kane or kane
california
okay is that the last game i'll have
played
that was a suiting way to end 2020 right
i think
it's like a these are the eyes this is
kind of the half smile
happy new year happy new year
yeah thank you cpt nutty bar and thanks
everyone else i really appreciate
all the love and support and confetti
can i move the confetti so it's like oh
i can make the confetti more condensed
too
oh okay now i feel like the spelling bee
champion
i just have to not smile i guess
thanks for the game eric that was cool
to see your extra trap even after the
bishop landed on e3
oh yeah yeah you fell into one trap and
then you fell into
uh another thing whoa it's oh no my
pancake
gifting subs thanks oh my
oh oh my pancake always want to say oh
no my pancake
oh it's one minute left alexa count down
until new year's
okay here we go ten nine
eight wait is this exact countdown
five four three two
one happy new year hey happy new year
wait my time didn't change
[Music]
wait what happened hey it's new year
okay
hey it's 20 21. let's go
alexa stop dmca me
and thank you for the the countdown i do
appreciate it
yeah hopefully this isn't 2020 part two
this is 2021. oh i hear
oh i hear loud noises neighbors
let's go
wow people are like screaming my
neighbors aren't usually this
like loud i could turn off i'll turn off
my noise suppression filter
do people hear that
i think the mic still does a good job of
like blocking people or blocking
background noise out but let's go happy
new year
uh at least a central time zone yeah and
everything east of central time zone
okay let's go
honestly it was not expecting to
[Music]
at least like last year i would not have
expected to
uh happy new year have a stream like
this this is great
enjoying chess i wrote my uni
dissertation a couple of years ago in
computer science for which i wrote a
chat
and i finally enjoy the game again oh
well that's nice to be here thank you
hawkseye
or hoxie oh yes happy 2020-1
yeah okay new year i hope
people are having a good start to their
new year
happy new year eric can move on
forgetting that's a very good thing
thank you to yeah thanks to everyone who
helped also
happy new year eric such a joy to be
streaming
[Music]
thanks to future youtube people too if
this goes on youtube
uh man the neighbors are really yelling
loud
um i have to maybe offer them some
calming tea